[Arabic recitation]
authored by
the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah's observation.
[Arabic recitation]
authority of the other on the authority
of
says to
the students or the people of his
time. So this is very contextual and
that is that
as we've heard many times he's one of
the last companions
of all to pass away and the reason for
that is that when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam came to Medina he
was how old?
10 years old. He was just a little boy.
But the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
made dua for anis and he made dua that
Allah give him a long life. And so
lived
very very very long.
Some estimate his lifespan to be over
120 years old.
And so
was one of the last of the companions to
pass away. So first of all he was young.
Second of all, he
lived a very very long time and
would later prove to be one of the most
critical companions
in the time of the why because
many of the older companions passed away
and it fell on his shoulders to narrate
and to transmit
the
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam
in their place. And
who said in this quote obviously he's
speaking to the people at the very end
of the time of
the
and
the beginning
of the time of
and during that time around the year 60
after Hijra
That's when all of the turmoil
and political problems started to crop
up and this is when there was a lot of
chaos etc. And this is when
innovation started to become
you know more prevalent and
introduced to the masses. And so
in this context said to the people
around him during those days, he
said,
He says, "You all are doing things today
that are more insignificant
than
a strain a strand of hair. things
that are so negligible,
things that you're taking for granted,
things that you look at them as being no
big deal at all. Right?
He says,
"Yet these things you all are doing
that you're overlooking,
no big deal."
In the time of the messenger of Allah,
we used to consider these things to be
deadly sins to be sins that were
absolutely grave that would mark the end
of
a person
and would
somewhat permanently damage a person's
relationship and a person's journey to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And this shows you how not only the
standards changed but that's not really
what NS is focused on. It's not just the
standards right
it is
the attitude of the followers. So when
we look at the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and he has his companions with
him
in 23 years they go from
total unknowns
to the fastest expanding empire
in the known world.
And within 30 years they have completely
dismantled every other empire. The Roman
Empire which had the Roman Empire had
hundreds of years of experience over
them and the Persian Empire which had
hundreds of years over the Roman Empire.
Right?
Yet they all
bent the knee to the Muslim. Why is
that? Was it just
Was it just luck? Was it just a series
of events that just worked out? Was it
the right place at the right time? Is
that what it was? Was it just a series
of events that just kind of fell into
place? Right. Right place at the right
time. Is that what it was? No, that's
not what it was. What it was is this
attitude right here. This attitude right
here.
if we were to capture
the essence
of
the era of the companions
and put it into words and say, give me a
sentence that captures that era. That
sentence would be
that would be their sentence.
We hear and we obey
everything. If we were to capture our
era and say capture that era in a
sentence,
I would I would say the sentence would
be do I have to,
right? Or maybe the sentence would be,
"Yeah, but I read on Google it was a
difference of opinion." Maybe that would
be the sentence that would capture our
time. Or maybe the sentence that would
capture our time would be
would be
is it wi
we re we receive a command of Allah his
messenger. We say, "Is it waj?
Is Allah going to literally burn me in
the flames of hell if I don't do it?
Because if not, I'm not really
interested." This
is the key difference. The companions
when they received a command, they
looked at it as an opportunity. See,
they want to worship Allah more. They
want more.
And so every time a command came that
was another
it was almost they were be being
given more and more space to express
their enthusiasm
and
this marks a key difference
in our view of what the messenger came
to do.
So the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam was described in the Quran
as coming to humanity
to keep them away from evil,
command them with good
and it was described his most prominent
description is that he comes to release
humanity
from their bondage
from the yolks and chains
that enslave them.
This is the
one of the most prominent of his
descriptions.
Look at that description.
He comes to humanity.
Humanity is not practicing a religion.
Humanity is doing whatever they want,
right?
Free reign to their free will.
And so as a result,
it's it's it's like
living in the wild amongst wild animals.
If you're strong,
you might get ahead a little bit. If you
are weak or meek, you will get eaten
alive.
And so
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam comes to humanity
and Allah refers to that quote unquote
freedom that they were experiencing
as chains and bondage and slavery,
right?
And the Quran and the Sunnah and the
light of revelation
is releasing them.
Releasing them from the chains that they
are in.
The companions saw
the Quran and Sunnah to mean that
that the Quran and Sunnah came
to release me from slavery to anyone or
anything other than Allah to emancipate
me, to free me.
And that is why
they took up every single drop of it.
And the most precious thing in the world
to them was their relationship with
Allah
and their journey to Allah.
And
anything that would threaten that
relationship or threaten to damage it or
impede it, they would steer very clear
from it.
But what we have been able what what the
people of our time have or the not just
the disbelievers but even amongst the
Muslim
what they have been able to
convince many of the Muslim of is that
it is exactly the opposite
right Islam doesn't come and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam doesn't
represent freedom.
He represents
slavery, bondage, putting a damper on
things. I can't do this. I can't do
that. Right? It's you know, I can't
do what I want to do, when I want to do
it, and how I want to do it. I'm not
allowed to do this. Everything is haram.
The haram bug, the haram police, right?
All these buzzwords people use to make
fun of the people that command the good
and forbid the evil. The people that
don't take a step forward without
verifying with Allah and his messenger
and the scholars of Islam, the
representatives of Allah and his
messenger. And so the I the stigma is
that no if if you you know if you the
stigma to a woman is if I marry a man
that is religious not religious if I
marry a man that is on the sunnah the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he's going to be a terrorist he's
going to be extreme and he's going to be
a caveman and I'm not going to be
allowed to do anything and I'm not going
to be allowed to go anywhere and I'm
going to be a slave. save and I just
have to cook all day. I have to just
clean all day and I have to be his
little pet and blah blah blah. You know
what people, you know where we got this
from? From the enemies that exactly
stepped on our necks that exactly
exploited our women. Why did they come
up with that? In order to get our women
out of their houses so that they could
have atom. That's exactly what happened.
That's how it happened. Do you think our
women would have been exploited if our
men didn't allow that to happen? That's
what happened.
How did that happen? Because we allowed
them to exploit them.
Said, "No people are really, no Muslim,
no believers are ever dominated by their
enemies. Never.
It is only the believers that allow
their enemies to dominate them when they
disobey Allah and his messenger. That's
how we lose a battle. That's how we lose
a fight. That's the only way.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]